dans quelques minutes nous verrons que
baby sitting et rim avec speed dating
c'est à montigny une initiative plutôt
originale pour permettre aux parents de
trouver un moyen pour garder leurs
enfants pour l'instant nous faisons un
point avec catherine gelato bonsoir sur
les voeux de la commune de
voisins-le-bretonneux c'était vendredi
soir pour alexis piette au gymnase des
pyramides dans une ambiance de neige
forcément cette saison et puis
d'allemagne bah oui je vais vous
expliquer ça dans quelques instants et
la neige effectivement n'a pas empêché
les vicinaux à se déplacer nombreux
parmi les invités politiques il fallait
noter la présence de valérie pécresse
la députée de la circonscription il y
avait également le maire de montigny le
bretonneux michel laugier puis des
représentants des maires d'autres
communes pas les dire aussi qu'ils
avaient en même temps les voeux de la
verrière donc tout ne pouvait pas être
un voisin breton parlé hier sur ce plat
et oui tout à fait et vous disiez
allemagne va effectivement est ce
qu'aujourd'hui c'est le 50e anniversaire
du traité d'amitié franco allemand est
une importante délégation de la ville
allemande une mène deux voisins shenfeld
étaient présentes
la maire de la ville s'est d'ailleurs
exprimé dans un français on peut dire
parfait dans les amants parle bien
français
elle a évoqué un besoin de créativité et
une vision juste des choses pour sortir
de la crise
elle a également reçu la médaille d'or
de la ville vous parlez bien allemands
n'ont pas dit tout haut niveau notamment
par le bienfait pour savoir si les
français parlait bien le monde ici et
puis alexis piette ensuite enchaîné sur
un discours un peu plus politique
ah oui même vraiment politique 1 il a
été rapidement question des municipales
de mars 2014
alexis millette a rappelé qu'en mars
2014 il achèvera son troisième mandat en
tant que maire et en fin de discours il
a annoncé que les membres de
l'association voisins ma ville s'étaient
réunis pour faire le choix de proposer
un nouveau projet pour voisin projet qu
alexis piette espère avoir l'honneur de
conduire ont hissé au top 10 s'est
déclaré candidat pour 2014 municipales
en mars un discours où il n'a pas été
tendre à l'encontre notamment du
processus d'intercommunalité
et vous savez c'était une obligation les
villes doivent maintenant se réunir en
intercommunalité alexis piette a
regretté que la communauté
d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines ne
s'agrandisse pas là où selon lui il y
avait de la place de versailles à la
vallée de chevreuse aux grands résultats
ont été préférés les petits calculs a
déclaré
l'élu des petits calculs sous entendu
politique est un peu saignant dans son
discours alexis piette et forcément il s
y était question de politique nationale
pour dénoncer le fonds de péréquation
qui pénalise les communes selon louis un
fonds de redistribution financière en
2012 la ville versera six cent mille
euros c'est bien ça oui et du coup
alexis bête a prévenu nous devrons
certainement renoncer au superflu mais
pour mieux garantir l'essentiel est
d'ailleurs à l'occasion de ses voeux pas
de champagne ni de petits fours mais
difficilement partager les galettes et
les pâtisseries allemande réalisée par
les pâtissiers locaux ont pu aussi du
cidre du terroir l'heure est donc aux
économies mehal a fait néanmoins vraie
fête assure alexis piette qui a évoqué
des dossiers locaux forcément
construction de logements à venir
oui alors c'est même indispensable pour
cette commune qui perd des habitants
en 1996 la ville comptait treize mille
deux cents habitants ils sont
aujourd'hui 1000 de moins c'est beaucoup
et c'est donc indispensable de
reconquérir des habitants pour retrouver
notamment des recettes il faut du
logement et du logement aidé du logement
social a prévenu l'élu c'est
l'aménagement du quartier de la merise
sur 9 hectares de friches 450 logements
sont prévus le coeur de ville a
accueilli et cette année ses premiers
habitants c'est bien mais le maire a
aussi regretté les recours déposé en
justice pour l'aménagement du maire en
tête qui pénalise le lancement de ce
programme malgré dit-il différentes
séances de concertation et pour finir
cette cérémonie comme l'ensemble des
maires un retour sur quelques unes des
réalisations de 2010 en 2012 c'est
notamment le nouveau groupe scolaire de
la santé carrière la nouvelle maison
culturel decauville et puis à l'ordre du
jour de 2013 un projet de réhabilitation
d'une partie du centre sportif des
pyramides l'envoi nouvelle maison de
covile d'un projet centre sportif des
pyramides qui pourra être réhabilité le
dossier a été déposé auprès du conseil
général et puis il a terminé son
discours alexis piette en appelant à la
confiance il a laissé aussi la parole à
valérie pécresse c'est la députée de la
circonscription qui a rappelé qu'elle
serait toujours aux côtés de voisin
breton a donc apporté son large soutien
alexis piette et forcément on parle
comme à chaque fois des municipales on
le voit bien merci catherine prochain
point sur ces différents rendez-vous des
politiques avec les personnalités de
leur commune ce sera demain
10 nous parlons de montigny le
bretonneux